okay Mary where are we right now well I
think we're we're in an office and we're
sitting down and there's a table in
front of us with a notebook and yeah we
just played that game keep talking and
nobody explodes and inside that notebook
is a bunch of bombs essentially you open
the notebook you find a bomb and then I
have to talk to you who's got a bunch of
paper to figure out how to defuse the
bomb that's right what's so interesting
about this style of game is a lot of VR
games are so about immersion or
pretending that you're there and this
game does it in such a different way
it's not about you visually feeling like
you're in the room because it looks so
real it's not really about the visuals
it's about the feeling of fear that you
get that this bomb is going to go off
and I have to talk to someone who can't
see it right and so yeah the person
who's giving instructions can't see the
bottom either right so it's this you
know imagine you're a remote bomb
detonation expert like in a shaft and
like a big office building and you're
over radio to somebody it's kind of like
replicating that experience how many
white where's one cut the fourth wire
bingo what's really great about it and
you know goes into the headsets are
wearing is this is mobile VR this is
running off to different Samsung devices
it's not going to do a PC it's just
using typical cell phones it's amazing
how I think this kind of hardware is
perceived I think that people perceive
VR is incredibly expensive and
cumbersome something that is difficult
for the everyday person to acquire but
this is actually only two hundred
dollars yeah and then you just basically
pop a phone in it and then you got
yourself a VR headset and this isn't the
only example of this I mean there are
cardboard VR things that you build
yourself and you can put pretty much any
phone in there Samsung is working with
oculus so they've got this sort of layer
of software that other people don't
which does make this the best sort of
mobile driven VR experience but yeah
it's two hundred dollars and you can go
buy the best buy you don't have to wait
for like the oculus order to open like
it than that if you just want to try VR
this is a great way to do it and this is
a great example of what you can do with
it yeah I don't think there's a much
better example
of how great this works then the game
keep talking and no one explodes because
it's so wonderful to just play with a
few friends in a room I mean it is
amazing when you put it on and I'm
explaining to you what the bomb looks
like and I'm describing how many
batteries or how many wires what colors
they are and you're looking through all
these papers really quickly and we're
panicking and there's only ten seconds
left and I start to sweat thinking I'm
actually going to explode I mean you
really feel the pressure I do believe
that the more people that try they are
the more there will be believers NVR you
don't want a half-baked experience so
this game gives you a really good
experience and it makes it more
accessible to everyone yeah all right
yeah suck it bomb suck it